I got to sit front row at the Louis
Vuitton show it was two people in my
seat it was another lady in the seat she
was this journalist from Beijing we were
in the same seat so we just split it up
and then next to us was supposed to be
split it up so at first you did she said
we almost said yo so I go and I see her
sitting like close to the end but I know
my seat is the end so I like go to sit
down and usually when you go to sit down
like the person moves over a little bit
she did not budge oh really and I was
like God damn Great Wall thank God dub
you know started like truffling and she
showed her seat same thing so we just
snuggled up Tyra Banks comes Tyra's
we're right next to her so it went me
her Tyra all these people had moved
there's no room for tyrant Tyra comes up
to these young people who are excited
about fashion this is Tyra Banks
goes uh hey my seat is right there uh
can you guys slide over they didn't even
acknowledge the question was asked wow
Next Level how did she respond I was
ignoring too so I didn't really
I was scared she was gonna ask me to sit
down am I supposed to do